hey party people welcome back to the old
school uh version of honest trailer
commentaries where we don't have to
leave our bedrooms uh do not be alarmed
this is just a temporary thing because
what would we call it we call it
tangentially covered related
uh people got kovid
who
live with people who work
with us and we're just waiting until we
get the all clear to come back in it's
my roommate's fault you could just say
well it's ryan's roommate
i'll name him first and last name
look i am all about the being careful i
just had to do that because i thought
that i was exposed and so like i wound
up missing some stuff last weekend it's
just about like uh caring for other
people y'all yeah that's uh
it's just you know what we were exposed
to we were exposed to halo the the
television series i've had covered and
i've had halo and i'm not sure
speaking of things that should have been
quarantined yeah although the series
no vaccine could save us we uh we watch
this we'll give you our behind the
scenes thoughts uh go into detail um for
those of you who sat through it with us
congratulations um you'll have a place
to vent here what's the opposite of
congratulations
condolences condolences yeah
we'll do uh questions and comments so
keep those coming in the chat uh we have
some deleted scenes and we'll tease you
with next week's honest trailer um at
the very end so
uh broad strokes halo
this show was was cheeks the show was
asked you just literally and
figuratively booty butt cheeks yes it
was um
look i i know that uh
i'm okay with them changing things uh
from the games and making it an
adaptation making its own world its own
parallel universe
i just don't get why they changed what
they did it seems like they almost did
it at random um or or they started with
a completely different template for a tv
show and then like the license for halo
just like dropped into their laps like
well we'll make it fit we'll make this
like generic hero fantasy story about
like the chosen one
granted the master chief is kind of that
still
it was just a series of baffling choices
for me um that made it uh you'd think
would make it interesting to watch but
it didn't
what are you guys overall take on halo
yeah we were talking about this uh
before we got on air it just could have
been anything it could have been any
show like this wasn't
to me this didn't feel like a halo show
and i was watching it and i was like
we're gonna we're gonna get to the
halo-ness of this soon like every
episode i'm just like it's coming and at
the end of the season i'm like they're
setting it up for season two season two
is when it's gonna start to get really
halloween it's like i don't know if you
have me for a season too
well
i'm surprised it just says i don't know
that much about halo lore like i played
the games but usually multiplayer so
like for me halo is about like a bunch
of space marines like jumping around
corners as high as they can while
they're shooting so yeah while children
yell racial epithets at you yeah like
it's i don't so i went in like okay i'm
ready for whatever they've got in mind
as long as it feels like it captures the
essence of halo which to me would be
almost like i was thinking it was going
to be more like a war show like they got
missions they're a team you know we're
getting an overall story about how the
spartan program fits in and the overall
war but i sort of thought there'd be
more of that and then you see the pilot
they obviously change a lot but there is
a battle in it so i i was watching this
like week to week on paramount plus in
real time
and after that i thought okay fans might
be upset because they're obviously
changing a bunch of stuff you know
master chief showing his face and
whatever but as long as they get the
combat right and they make it feel like
the action scenes are hitting i felt
like people would go with it and then
there's like five episodes in a row with
no action and like i feel like that's my
real my real
nitpick not nitpick my real complaint is
not that it doesn't feel like the games
but that it's just not it's like it
doesn't feel interesting or compelling
it just feels like a lot of talk talk
talk in small rooms like a sci-fi
original from the early aughts or
something and i feel like that's where
it really loses the halo-ness yeah i
would never call this a a war show or a
war story whereas halo the games if
nothing else they're the stories of a
interstellar war that he's thrust in in
the middle
combat evolved not talking of all
[Laughter]
all right well let's uh lots more to say
but let's start and stop as we go for
our honest trailer of hello
the show oh hello
hold up
[Music]
the league of legends show was good even
the sonic movies were decent now as a
new era dawns for video game adaptations
a series will remind us don't get too
excited they're still usually ass
[Music]
pause right there no i want to see those
ass cheeks well i just wonder
they
could they was this r-rated could they
have done
like
gore and nudity and stuff like that
because like why is there so much but in
this show
that's my question it does feel i mean i
guess they could it's on paramount plus
they were originally making it for
showtime so you feel like they were
probably leaning even more in in the
showtime era to like yeah it's gonna be
really edgy and like push the envelope
because that's that's sort of showtime's
whole deal uh so i'm betting they pulled
that back a little when it shifted to
paramount plus i feel like we have all
these butt scenes right they're still
obviously coding it is like this ain't
your this ain't your little brother's
halo show this is for the adults in the
reno like they're they're coding it that
way they're sex scenes it's a little bit
bloody violent you know yeah yeah weird
they're trying to they're trying to hint
that it's got more of like uh like a you
know verhoven vibe than a spielberg yeah
yeah which i i and i do y'all know i
love a bear hogan yeah it even you know
without any of the cleverness or the
satirical just winking and yeah
it's very um
and i love a good butt but
there was a lot of butt butts
burn gorman you got to work on those
cakes
why him
well i have a lot of questions about his
character but we'll get to those we'll
get to those later i don't mind any of
that like make a more mature themed halo
show that sounds good to me but it does
have to just butts isn't going to do it
i was surprised it was like
yeah it was like wasn't the show that
had a lot of butts in it that i liked um
the americans had a lot of nice butts in
it yeah
the shield was pretty buddy yeah yeah
all right because fx is another one of
those networks that's like oh it's a
little bit adult you know there's a
little where this little channel for mom
and dad
i keep playing halo
microsoft tried for decades to bring
halo to hollywood but after bailing on
movies from great directors bailing on
shows from the best producers and
bailing on showrunners who even looked
at the game they'll bail on even trying
to adapt the game's storyline so pause
for this um
i guess which of the which of the failed
versions of this would you have liked to
see uh mine is peter jackson's i think
that he could have taken on the scope
and just filmed it like new zealand
looks like a halo anyways you just kind
of crop the sides of any landscape in
new zealand and you're there
and he knows how to do cgi uh
battle scenes and and armies and i think
he would have absolutely knocked this
one out of the park the horde come on
yeah so hardy yeah very horrible yeah i
mean obviously spielberg you see his
name flash across there and like i would
never say no to spielberg take on a big
sci-fi franchise but i also think the
ridley scott version i'm super intrigued
he produced uh raised by wolves which
just got canceled after two seasons
which also not the greatest series but
in terms of the
ambition and scale and like the the
cleverness and imagination of it it's
light years beyond no punishment it's
way way beyond the halo series so like i
would have liked to see somebody like
that who's really gonna like push the
creative team further to do more with it
than like this which feels very much
like a yeah you know let's throw
together something kind of haloy i
didn't really dive into uh the the
history of this uh ip but like why
whose fault is it that that didn't end
up working out is it just everybody like
there wasn't enough money or something
because there's every one of those
choices is better than what we got it's
it's it's hard to say i think it's
because you're you're dealing with it's
one of those kind of situations where
it's not just like a studio owns an ip
outright and they can do whatever they
want you're talking about these two
huge you got to work with microsoft all
and the studio and then within microsoft
you've got the team that works you know
like there's a lot of stakeholders and i
think anytime you do that is when you
get these like really long complicated
you know like what we see with bond
movies wherever once well i'll be like
and then there was eight years with no
bond movies because everybody was suing
everybody and like but i can't imagine
that this is what everybody it seems
like they just like shrugged their
shoulders and said fine you know we'll
we'll do this this can't be what they
were building towards yeah
this is literally one of those things
that had streaming not become what it
became this would not have happened this
was literally just like we have this
platform we can't just put on old
episodes of all that so we're gonna need
to put something else on here yeah
that's exactly it it was this was in
development at show time this probably
would have been the latest version that
got thrown in to turn around but they
were like ah we got to throw stuff at
paramount plus yellowstone's going to
peacock no
so that's where that's where you get it
all right
okay keep going yo that bailed on
terminator the turtles and transformers
on mtv and avatar man paramount is just
dangling from tom cruise's giant nods
follow along on the master chief's
evolution from a no-nonsense soldier who
never takes his helmet off to a
helmetless rebel who disobeys orders and
turns on his creator which is fine at
the show built up to all that but since
it happens in episode 1 there's nothing
left to do for the other eight hours
except
[Music]
yeah positive
i think this is the core weakness of the
of the show is that
not that they make master chief you know
uh against his character that we're used
to
um or that they have him crack jokes or
learn to feel or
uh
fight the usmc or anything it's that
they do he makes every significant
choice in episode one and then the other
eight is him kind of waffling and sort
of regretting but not but finding his
own way there's no build up to the to
the massive changes that they've made
which is
not dramatic
there's just no drama in if there's
nothing compelling when he's done
everything
he's past the point of no return in
episode one and you're just watching him
sort of kind of muddle through uh how he
feels about that for the other eight
we've also seen that story a billion
times like i if there was one new
wrinkle they had on it like the super
soldier learns that he was programmed
and like what is free will and you know
like
i didn't have a choice and like i don't
know i would have liked them to come up
with it's fine to introduce that but you
got to give me a new direction or a turn
or a wrinkle or something i don't see
coming because otherwise yeah it's just
going through the motions for the whole
season of this story we've heard
many many times before maybe it's even
like 11 from stranger things it's the
same story there basically yeah
yeah super boring um
find a new find a new angle if the
government wants to make her a weapon
like the fire starter this is a tragedy
and usually they have the good sense to
keep them emotionless killing machines
until like part way through
because at least then you get some good
action shots out of it pablo schreiber
uh you know dennis thieves is a pretty
good actor he only played it oh he's
like he's gonna he could have played
that over season one like i feel like
it's also a bummer from his perspective
that they basically don't let him
actually show you the development of
master chief it all happens at once and
then he broods for literally like eight
episodes and it's real like you could do
so much more with that he just like
stares into the middle distance it's all
about reclaiming his childhood memories
of a single day that we get like seven
frames up at a time right every time he
touches the big rock he has to touch the
artifact or cover the memory so the rest
of the time he's just wandered around
and it's very not active because we know
he can't do anything without touching
the rock
that's like the career of ryan reynolds
he can't do much without touching the
rock yeah
all right
to be fair you can't write a whole
series about an honorable space warrior
whose face you never see
uh twice you couldn't do that twice
but she's not alone meet a team slayer's
worth of characters like quan a girl
with a backstory as tragic as her
haircut
soarin who runs a libertarian hideout
functional enough to make churros i only
got churros today
yes it's hot all right give me half a
dozen the bad sci-fi dr halsey a
character based on the showrunner and
that she doesn't care what people think
about her work and she's ruined a bunch
of childhoods miranda keys a strong
woman of color who won't be denied her
place as the usmc's next joseph mengele
other spartans like kai one twenty two
five who follow chief's
uh there's two things that they set up
and never really
dug into
in a very bizarre
way one is quan
and they really set up you know it's
gonna be like lone wolf and cub like uh
kwan's gonna help master chief open up
and they're gonna go on adventures
together he dropped her off at daycare
at libertarian daycare never do that by
the way
um
uh and then they uh they split up for
the rest of the show um and there's not
even an indication like they're not even
looking for each other it's not like
these two characters are being drawn
back together narratively and they're
just like pushing that off to season two
it's basically like well they'll never
meet again on to further halo a yeah
and the other thing that the first two
episodes do which are never followed up
on um and it relates to keys or the i
guess the keys family is they set up
that the usmc is you know a tyrannical
ruthless
uh
murderous killer you know juggernaut of
an empire uh that's willing to mow down
uh teenage girls and they're just there
to extract as much resources and move on
and that's never
questioned or spoken about again really
it's like it's still just as evil
at the end as in the first two episodes
when master chief is like whoa really
that's messed up but like
i guess
the conflict is between the usnc and the
colonists like it's this rift within
humanity and then the covenant just like
this external threat but then after the
pilot we basically forget about the
colonists almost entirely plot-wise and
it's just about humanity versus this
evil theocratic alien menace right uh so
i'm assuming again that they're kicking
that can down the road and season two
will bring back that conflict and we've
certainly seen that there are evil there
are like bad apples within usnc but
season one almost suggests like at core
it's it's made up of mostly good people
and there's just like there's yeah no it
seems like institutionally
that they're just like uh they're evil
as a
as
an idea you know right and then we're
supposed to cheer for her when she gets
a promotion like okay now you're in
charge of harvesting babies
you broke that ceiling one person by the
end of the season you'd be forgiven for
thinking that dr halsey was the bad guy
and everyone else in unsc is pretty good
no she was doing everything in secret
they were running the the the child
murdering farms but i mean like it's all
over with but you never really like
everybody there's no bad characters in
unsc other than natasha mcelroy like
she's the only one yeah everybody else
is like nice so how are we supposed to
see this as like an evil it would be
like if the empire like the emperor
was bad
but everybody else was like well we're
just trying to run this death star the
best we can i guess we should you know
it's like below decks do you really want
to kill the entire planet of alderaan
that seems extreme maybe we should talk
to palpatine yeah
yeah really some real uh narrative
dissonance there i found uh when they
were like we're really just gonna spend
time with all these like the the third
reich uh functionaries that are oh but
they're really good at right but they're
all all protagonists except
literally one of them like one bad
person in this entire universe
yeah okay and she
it was so funny she's well-meaning she's
just she's just immoral she just goes
about it the wrong way but her heart's
not right but she's well-meaning like
she wants to do good
i mean i guess it's like
you you can only have
there were only like three people in the
entire uh galaxy in the show
but he's always bad but they had to make
her
so smart and have her do so many things
because they just didn't have enough
characters on the show that she's in
charge of cortana she's in charge of
human cloning she's in charge of the
spartan program she's in charge of the
entire usmc's like science division it
was just dr keys are the only two people
who know science
very advanced technological version of
humanity with two scientists yeah where
did she find the time
um
yeah
so she landed on sleeping
in the same fields of science she's
making like computer science
advancements and cloning research and
like yeah it just adds to the like it's
clearly they spent a lot of money and
yet it feels small because this whole
thing is about maybe four or five main
characters right what was her major
everything
science
science
all right keep going feed by literally
pulling the emotions out of her butt
mckee the most consistently shocked
character in tv history
she died as she lived being surprised
and cortana the ai personal assistant
that's a bit like having clippy drilled
into your skull against your will
but hey at least they got the original
voice actors to player any halo fans
stick around till episode three no you
went back to playing halo huh well i
didn't have that option
since 2001 gamers have been dreaming of
what halo would look like in live action
that day has finally come but it looks
like 2001 is when they stopped improving
the graphics with just three goofy
looking battle scenes spread across nine
hours and nothing for halo's core fans
to enjoy in between except that move
where you swap guns with a marine yeah
we'll just take a moment
i know they've already been piled on but
that tweet that was like
uh say what you will about the halo
series but this is the action scene that
we've all been dreaming of
okay
if it doesn't look better than the game
why are we here
yeah it has that problem that a lot of
the early
like when they when they first started
to replace humans on screen in action
scenes with like digital stunt men oh
yeah i love blade too this is not a
knock on guillermo but but blade two had
a little bit of that where it's like
they just kind of look rubbery like they
weren't perfect at capturing like how
humans move in space yet yeah so you
would get like a digital stuntman
they're like their
limbs are a little loose it just doesn't
quite look like how a person moves and
this has that problem a lot you can even
see in that shot we pulled the master
chief jumping onto the
spacecraft that's in motion
it just kind of like you can i mean i
don't expect them to do that practically
but master chief oh i don't know
practically but it's just like
the effects look like
like a previous generation but for so
i'm saying for some of it like if it's a
fight between master chief and
one of the alien elite guards or
whatever you can do that practically
they both are human shaped and sized and
you can shoot that
aliens in this i think every alien is
like totally a digital creation i think
i don't think i saw a practical suit no
no no but yeah i'm just saying you could
if you had
a budget like that that stretched on to
infinity you could do a fight scene
between
two guys in suits and then and then made
it look better with effects instead of
just starting with the with the maya 3d
template first this was definitely not a
netflix like sky's the limit unlimited
budget this was always like cbs studios
like this this had a this no i think
this is i think this was maybe i'm just
maybe overall on the project they just
they probably had to spend like a
million dollars in that right but kill
fees when they cancel on spielberg sorry
this was cbs television so like there
were more like responsible people like
watching the actual ledger it wasn't it
wasn't like a you know a netflix 250 mil
spending spree interesting yeah well oh
well
all right keep going dog ride
[Applause]
[Music]
same with the halo games
you know to be fair it's not just a
mcguffin it's also the deus ex machina
for ending any scene
yeah uh pause just briefly um touching
it at one point makes
uh a ship
stop working and then at another point
makes the exact same ship start working
again so it's really just whatever you
want make your dreams come true make a
wish and then touch them it's the
wishing rock from uh wonder woman
they're a little too and i get looked
it's hard to write a show and like a lot
of the time you find yourself in a
scenario where it's like okay
the good guys need to get we've written
them into this corner and the good guys
need to get away and i don't have an
easy way for the good guys to get away
oh the rock explodes and everybody
passes out but like you can only do that
so many times like and i'm like look
that's that's how that's how writing
works again but like you can only do
that so many times before it starts to
like become obvious that that's what
you're doing you're gonna touch the rock
it's gonna explode
people that don't need to pass out and
they'll get away i think they lean on
that like one or two times too many to
where it's like well she's just going to
touch the rock and then she's going to
get to run out of that like yep sure
enough touch the rock i just think you
saved the rock touching until last you
know
yeah
yeah yeah she's also at kevin hart's
contract
how dare you
keep going
[Applause]
we really could have used this when
cortana was watching master chief have
sex
do you think he's tea bagging
fear the covenant a horrifying glimpse
of what would happen if the star wars
trade federation found religion who live
inside a big floating mushroom tip and
have a generic evil plan to activate the
mysterious halo but since they spend the
whole season looking for the halo we
only get a tiny glimpse of the halo and
even then they're pretty vague about why
they want a halo meaning if you wanted a
show set on halo you can probably just
start with season two of halo now with
bits of actual halo halo is an
adaptation that takes great license with
the source material paramount global
three four three industries not promised
halo appeared in hilo season two you're
demanding to see a deadly hidden ring
are encouraged to look at their own
buttholes
so enjoy a return to the battle days of
video game adaptation where instead of
pleasing the game's fans and relying on
them to tell the normies how good it is
they'll take gamers for granted and try
to appeal to a broad audience of nfl
dads and their teenage sons because halo
is one of those niche things that only
the most hopeless nerds could care about
right it's only so let's see here 80
million copies
this i'm going to rewatch red versus
blue instead so fuzz
i understand like
uh either if the narrative is so thin
that there's nothing there
i understand the mario brothers movie
more than i understand this because
there's not much there and it's just
they they're a plumber they jump on the
head
if you were like hey it's the early 90s
i want you to make the mushroom kingdom
in live action you'd be like what about
if it's just a city
and there's mushrooms growing like right
you know like you just have like it's
the masters of the universe it's not
like they didn't want to do eternia they
just like ah we can't afford it how
about the parking lot behind this
chicken restaurant yeah uh now the
lights are out
and i think like you know but you don't
have to do that with with halo the
series like
i don't know yeah and i also understand
so i understand if it if the video game
doesn't have much of a story and i also
understand if it's a more niche title
for an adaptation like prince of persia
you're like okay people
maybe didn't sell a bazillion copies
well we'll start from the beginning
we'll tell our own tale of jake
gyllenhaal the prince of persia you know
persian film star jake gyllenhaal but
halo is a narratively driven game and
more than like a third of the united
states has played it so
just start there just start there you
don't have to stick to it but just like
don't run away from that because it's
huge and it's got a story i was saying
before like i don't really think you
need to follow the the storyline of the
games so clearly but like a setting it
just needs to it just needs to have a
halo vibe and aesthetic like you could
make a show that doesn't have the same
story but if it was about the spartans
and they've got missions and they're
fighting the covenant and these episodes
and their missions and their the things
that they're doing resemble the kinds of
things they do in the games i think that
would have been totally good enough and
you can make the
specifics of the narrative and how
things unfold different but if you're
like what if we forget about all the
combat and the action and we may get
this like
thriller about what who could truly be
claiming his childhood the nature of
free will and duty and like nobody cares
like what are you doing like that's not
what halo is
at least with captain marvel we got to
watch a little girl fall down a bunch
that's right
that's right
um could use more quan falling down
she falls down some just not enough yeah
she doesn't cause she has a couple falls
all right let's wrap this up
what is that thing
one thing there's something on your head
what is it a spider get it off it's like
a blue thing like a blue spider
starring
master bait blues clues
cerebral halsey
mckees nuts
fem chef she comes from the planet
madrigal i used to be a spartan like you
then i took a griddle to the arm
bern gorman once again his real name is
burn gorman
and starry krishnas
board of the ring
all right i forgot quan is actually part
of an ancient bloodline destined to
protect a mysterious portal hidden by a
white dreadlock tribe at the bottom of a
well it doesn't matter at all in the
show but well now you know and knowing
is half the run time
yeah
unbelievable that there were
entire episodes dedicated to quan and
soren
finding out you know trying to liberate
her hometown from the the the quizling
byrne gorman and uh
what it amounted to was that she found
out that she's like a luke skywalker
type she's very luke skywalker that was
that was something you had in your notes
right lon
she's like a desert kid who's
yeah it's a very
it's another like it's a chosen one
narrative within another chosen one
there we've got
not only is it like repetitive in that
there's two other chosen shows there's
chosen twos is that
again it undermines all of the political
conflict that they set up in the first
two episodes of like your father
is resisting the usmc because you're an
exploited colony and you're uh you know
fighting for your rights and you want
freedom from this oppressive regime
no
actually he fell at the bottom to the
bottom of a well
and some mystic people told him that
this was his birthright and he is the
magic keeper of the whole and and that's
why he's resisting not because of the
any kind of exploitation happening
it's just it's just
it's it's gabagool it is
unnecessarily complicated like and and
immediately we saw from game of thrones
too the the balancing of like fantasy
magic enchantment stuff and like real
world political historically inspired
like it's it's it's it's easy to go back
and forth it's hard to blend like it's
hard to bring those two worlds together
because you know the the more realistic
political storylines naturally reject
like and then we solve it with a spell
you know and like and i feel like game
of thrones didn't always figure this out
well this show
does not figure it out at all like they
do not do a good job of balancing those
two aspects of it and they basically by
episode three the political stuff is
like
yeah we got we got aliens to uh watch
look for something else i will say i did
like the design and the look of uh bokeh
woodbines like asteroid colony where
it's like a bunch of asteroids together
that they've colonized and like they're
now they've strung these like train cars
between them it's a very cool
design it kind of reminded me of uh the
mars colony and total recall
and then like it's futuristic but it's
also gross and disgusting and like an
80s
you know like ruined city kind of look
uh yeah so that we did have a whole
subplot about who rules the ruined city
with no rules
and like i almost feel like that's the
that's a more interesting show i feel
like i've seen less about ruin future
city on an asteroid and like people
squabbling about who get to control it
than the halos yeah
uh you know we haven't seen his deleted
scenes let's see if we cut anything out
of this
starring
huddy
universal soldier
porn stash is that you
quippy
dr science md
mars needs mobs abduct dynasty
hey mickey you're so fine blessed side
story
ah the glass cage of emotion
ioi 143
wrath of quan
stop looking at me quan
snorin
first person looter
vladimir putin
and literal [ __ ]
starship poopers
ass effect
star wars visions
not another halo series
well there you go a lot of butt jokes in
this one
that's the show they gave us uh
they must be making a mass effect show
right
yeah uh that netflix i think is netflix
or amazon one of them as well hopefully
they they got a good sense of what not
to do
um
what else do we do in the show oh
questions uh
they are it's amazing amazon is working
on the mass effect nice
um
let's see adam halbert uh it's kind of a
check-in on neil blomkamp is he still a
great director his last movie demonic
was so bad i gave up getting excited for
the district nine sequel
i think
i don't i'm not willing to write him off
yet but it's district nine remains the
one
groundbreaking
film on his resume uh as much as
anything on that alien show right now
is that oh no that's noah holly i don't
know yeah um i love i love uh
chappie as a meme but
not so much as a yeah
uh so yeah that's a that's a bummer but
you know there's a lot of great uh
up-and-coming sci-fi directors uh these
days so um oh i guess he's working on a
gran turismo movie oh no
what
i'm i'm reading it from deadline this is
from june 4th district just last
uh
2023 release date for gran turismo the
video game adaptation from director neil
blom camp at columbia pictures yeah he's
at sony making a gran turismo film
there's no story at least i don't think
there's a story i thought it was just
car stuff yeah it'll be a car race movie
shark cargo room yeah um
okay what uh
cargo firm let's see um and then also he
he moves on to say can we get your
thoughts on the prey trailer uh the
director says he was inspired visually
by the 2018 god of war game that's cool
well hopefully he was also inspired by
the
uh
19 predator 89 predator films
basics yeah
i thought it looked cool i love the the
um idea of a
uh
what do you call it an anthology series
of films of diff predators throughout
history predator 2 really kind of made
us this implicit promise at the at the
end of predator 2 that you see the
predators have all these like historical
artifacts like they've been visiting
throughout the history of humanity and
it does kind of set up like oh okay we
could get predator stories from all
kinds of different periods where they're
fighting you know humans from different
eras and uh comanche nation is an
awesome pick like a cool setting for a
movie that we haven't seen that much and
i think it looks great i'm really
excited yeah
uh mate valencia
regarding the nfl dads to justify
dumbing down the series aren't nfl dads
also xbox fans and didn't uh
uh d and d i guess that's the benny off
and weiss uh do it with uh game of
thrones
um
yeah that's that's again what's baffling
to me is like you already clearly had a
series that has been
played in one form or another from
everybody from people in their 40s to
young teenagers they've all played a
halo game so
your work's been done for you don't
really overthink it
that would that would be my note um i
don't understand them being like a dad's
never going to get a halo show a war
story uh in space dads don't like war
stories
it's like it feels very like
90s thinking like it just feels like a
network tv level decision where it's
like look a tv show you've got
characters you get to know and we see
their faces and they have personalities
and we're like
we're so far into the peak tv era people
have done all kinds of experimental
weird different things with shows like
at least try it it seems weird to be
like you could never make a show that
feels like halo that people would watch
like of course you could yeah right and
have and yes ben yeah d d is that i've
honestly lost my mind as far as game of
thrones goes d that those are the show
runners of game of thrones yeah db weiss
and david benioff yeah i knew they had d
names a couple of d's and i think that
yes they did dumb it down but i think
for different reasons it's because they
ran out of roadmap they ran out of like
source material to adapt so this was
it's like that finish uh
finish a horse drawing where like it
starts out very detailed and then you're
like okay
if you read a lot of the interviews with
them too it does kind of feel like once
they start like once game of thrones hit
a certain level of popularity and they
started getting all these other offers
and they started thinking about all the
other kinds of things they could do it
does feel like they just kind of
got a little distracted
i don't know i can't tell for sure but
uh luis valenzuela asks i forgot what
properties does paramount have that
they've yet to adapt
and which one would you save from them
but they've yet to adapt i'm not sure
but i know that they've got a ton they
don't have the strongest track record
with what they have like
star trek film wise star trek is is done
um or they can't seem to get it
okay i got i got a list we got so
beverly hills cop is them
never need to see that again i mean it's
great that's that's crocodile dundee
crocodile dead never need to see that
eventually good on you any neutron this
is telling me uh sure uh paranormal
activity we just got a new one of those
for paramount plus so that makes sense
that's like pocket change yeah sure uh
the ring
spy kids which is coming back they could
do another spy kids ninja turtles which
we mentioned
um you know and then there's everything
that's like mtv or nickelodeon so beavis
and butthead are coming back rugrats is
theirs you know anything you want to do
with any like nicktoons doug or whatever
you know like all that yeah aren't they
doing that uh the daria show that
centered on what was it judy i think
right it's darya's friend is getting her
own spin-off and oh like all the all the
uh a lot of the old bad robot stuff so
cloverfield
would be them as well oh they've got gi
joe i think yeah ryan's saying uh
they're bringing back the star trek cast
are they though is it that really
happening um and uh and then we did an
sju on it so that means yeah i mean
there it there is there's been some
confirmation that yeah like they're
going to try to do a star trek four with
like pine and yeah
and then last airbender which they uh
can't they just keep stepping on rakes
uh regarding that whole franchise so
that's talking about the the more
animated stuff from the creators not the
netflix kind of yeah
there's two there's two parallel avatar
development tracks but yeah avatar
studios which is the original creators
doing the animated stuff they're going
to release it through
nickelodeon paramount okay we'll see
we'll see uh we'll close with this uh
jeffrey elberton says uh this show looks
dumb what are you having for lunch
oh probably a sandwich a sandwich yeah
um
i was subtly eating it throughout the
whole uh show um
my uh child is obsessed with uh in kanto
so they made uh uh they made arepas and
handed me an arepa early on in the in
the show and i uh it was so good yeah
you can't let that thing go cold yeah i
can't let that go cold so i'm gonna have
to go get some more right after this uh
i had i ordered uh mexican food
yesterday and i still have most of my uh
quesadilla left over so i'm going to
have an al pastor
beautiful and worthy of a discussion
about halo is what we're having for
lunch
let's move on shall we to next week um
a show as well a better
[Music]
that i think is
after this
fantastic
a great palette cleanser um i mean you
don't need to tell them our honest
trailer for next week
there you go there's a clue
uh we'll see y'all then hopefully in
studio uh we plan on it um uh let's all
go to the studio next week you the
viewers we have seating for seven um all
right we'll see you then thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you